the President of the United States is
now threatening one of those states that
are part of the united states
specifically Alaska Republican senator
Lisa Murkowski from Alaska was one of
the seven Republicans who voted against
repealing parts of Obamacare a couple
days ago during one of these endless
Senate boats Trump didn't like it he
took to Twitter and said senator Lisa
Murkowski of the great state of Alaska
really let the Republicans and our
country down yesterday too bad
later in the day senator Murkowski and
dan sullivan the other republican
senator for alaska apparently received
calls from the Department of the
Interior warning them that the state's
future was now under consideration how
do you consider the future of a state
Pat well Alaska is the 49th state so I
guess it was considered for a while
until we finally took it in you know
Trump attacking individual members of
the US Senate who are Republicans is
pretty crazy though especially when a
lot of them come from these pink states
where Democrats could easily be elected
and take over their seats and I think
leadership understands that sometimes
their own members have to defect for the
greater good of keep securing their spot
yet when you start like Trump sees is if
you do what I want you're great and if
you don't you're the worst person in the
world but you might actually still need
Lisa Murkowski support or the support of
Alaska or whatever for other stuff that
you want to do and this just makes
absolutely no sense and the messages
came directly from the Interior
Secretary I'm not going to go into the
details but I fear that the strong
economic growth Pro Energy Pro mining
Pro jobs and personnel from Alaska who
are part of those policies are going to
stop a state is being threatened it's
sort of like if you don't screw your
residents by voting against Obamacare
we'll screw them anyway by doing things
that will hurt Alaska as a whole I don't
even get what this means like would
trump consider giving Alaska to Putin as
maybe collateral for one of those loans
that Trump owned to those two Russian
oligarchs this is what the mob does
right nice little state you got here
would really be a shame if something
were to happen to it I think maybe the
interior sucker
terry is taking a look at what's
happening to Jeff Sessions over at
justice yeah and deciding hey I got a
stick by Trump here because otherwise
he'll get rid of me and just to tell you
how wacky this is remember congressman
dana rohrabacher he's one of the
republican congressmen considered sort
of most Russia connected he's the one
that Kevin McCarthy said in that leaked
conversation with other Republicans last
year there's two people I think Putin
pays Dana Rohrabacher and Donald Trump
he actually once tweeted I know it
sounds crazy when I say what about
giving Alaska back to Russia Rohrabacher
once tweeted he'd be fine with Alaskans
deciding to go back to Russia or go to
Russia on April 2nd of 2014 he was
responding to another twitter user and
he said if majority of people legally
residing in alaska want to be part of
russia that it's okay with me the what
weary and what is the what's happening i
mean this doesn't make any sense and
there's absolutely no respect for the
institution of the US government the
important of checks and balances
whatsoever and wit are is the washington
post going to report tomorrow Trump has
been quietly asking advisers whether he
could give a state away yeah I mean I
think we suspected that a lot could fall
apart if Obamacare was repealed but
certainly not the sovereignty of our
country and individual states seceding
from the Union let me play one of these
apologists why shouldn't we give States
to Russia I mean what's wrong with being
friendly with Russia anyway shouldn't we
want to be friends with all nations I
mean Hillary Clinton would have started
a war with Russia and Trump's being
really friendly and maybe he'll offer up
a state or two I don't know why we
should be against that today's program
is made possible in part by Gamefly
which is sort of like Netflix for video
games they've got over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can also stream games you don't
even need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30-day free trial at Gamefly
offer.com slashed edps the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included no contracts and you
can also stream the games I think I
mentioned that you can also rent games
through the mobile app get a free 30-day
trial for David Pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show at
Gamefly offer.com forward slash TDP s